[Music]
i'm kurumi mori for bloomberg quick take
it's been a long night carrying into
this morning and looking to be a long
week for the u.s presidential election
which remains too close to call joe
biden and donald trump both speaking
shortly ago
let's listen in
and well thank you very much
thank you very much please sir thank you
this is without question the latest news
conference i've ever had
thank you thank you
i appreciate it very much and i want to
thank the american people for their
tremendous support millions and millions
of people voted for us tonight
and a very sad group of people
is trying to disenfranchise that group
of people
and we won't stand for it we're going to
have to be patient
until we the hard work of tallying the
votes is finished
and it ain't over until every vote is
counted every ballot is counted
i'm here to tell you tonight we believe
we're on track to win this election
we're feeling good about where we are
but it may take a little longer as i've
said all along
it's not my place or donald trump's
place to declare who's won this election
that's the decision of the american
people but i'm optimistic about this
outcome
keep the faith guys we're gonna win this
joining me now to break it all down is
jordan fabian bloomberg's white house
correspondent in washington d.c
jordan what do you make of these two
statements
well you had one candidate joe biden who
gave a pretty conventional
post-election speech in a situation like
this where
the result is too close to the call
projecting confidence but saying
yeah it's not us who wins then you had
donald trump
really do something unprecedented which
is
falsely claimed victory argue that his
supporters are being disenfranchised and
saying that he's going to watch a legal
battle in the uf supreme court
to possibly stop voters votes from being
counted
and so uh we're just kind of in
uncharted territory here this has been a
very punishing
and divisive campaign and the
president's remarks would only
throw a fuel on the fire of that
divisiveness
yeah so what can we expect tomorrow and
going forward
well the votes are going to continue to
be counted tomorrow
despite the president's words there are
three key states where
the vote counting has been very slow
because of the volume
of mail and ballots due to the pandemic
that's michigan
wisconsin and pennsylvania now the the
officials in those states say that this
counts could take
uh possibly a few days so we might not
know the real winner here
until later this week but uh you should
i think all viewers should kind of look
to those states to see
uh what the progress is and you know joe
biden
if he was able to pick up any two of
those states
judging on the by the results tonight he
has a really good chance of
winning becoming the next president
right it's been an unusual election to
say the least because of kovan 19 you
mentioned with that
a record number of voters turning to
mail-in ballots
uh who has the upper hand now
right now it seems that joe biden is in
a pretty good position although the
president has run a very close
race and has a very real chance of
winning a second term
uh this associated press just called
arizona
uh for joe biden as we were coming on
air um so that really means he
he can even win without uh pennsylvania
which is that one of
the states or the mail on ballots could
really decide the result if he
wins back michigan and wisconsin and
holds on to nevada
uh he he will become the next president
and so
for the president he has to pick up uh
pennsylvania
michigan or wisconsin the combination of
those three
and that seems to be tough setting for
the president
just looking at the polls and the early
returns and knowing how many of those
early was still out there
because those early ballots tend to
favor democrats
so for now we may need to wait quite a
while maybe for the accurate
vote count is what it sounds like but
what exactly happens next what should we
be looking forward to next
keep your eyes on news organizations
like bloomberg and
and others who are going to be looking
at those
reports from the state governments that
that are tallying these results
and to see what the results are i mean
if we're getting
race calls uh from michigan wisconsin
and pennsylvania
those three states now seem to be the
ones that this race is coming down to
so keep an eye on those three very close
and lastly could there potentially be a
recount of any kind are lawyers
preparing uh for one
yeah legal teams from each side are
definitely preparing for
a legal battle although right now it
doesn't seem like
the results are in each in in states so
far
have gotten to that ki that point where
it's so close
uh that they would need to do a recount
i mean there are close races in georgia
north carolina
but uh this race might be determined
without knowing those so while
there could be recounts in those states
in the days and weeks ahead
there we might not be headed for a bush
versus gore situation like you saw in
2000
where ultimately the supreme court uh
kind of decided
who won that race uh that we might not
get to that point
about to wait and see as these early
votes come in
what the margins are in the western
states
where that would be where uh for
simpson's 2000. we do have a live map
of the results uh right now uh
looking at looking at this map um
what do you make of this these results
are these
were these expected any surprises for
you
democrats were hoping for an early
knockout of president trump tonight they
had
really had some confidence going in
looking at the polls showing that
vice president biden was leading in in
pretty much all these
key swing states but the president
pulled off some surprising victories
early in the night
really has had decisive victory in
florida pulled ahead in georgia north
carolina
and also one in ohio where uh biden
was trying to make a late charge and so
that really narrowed biden
by his path to victory it was only when
biden
picked up that victory in in arizona is
when the map started being favorable uh
for him again
so it's been sort of a roller coaster or
a night
for for democrats who came with
confidence
and then saw that the drop off but now
or
are somewhat confident once again uh and
for republicans
you know they still have power i don't
want to downplay the president's
chance of winning but it is an hour half
now
that uh the vice president biden has won
arizona and jordan as
a reporter how has it been covering the
election so far tonight well this
morning now
yeah it's been it's been a wild and
chaotic night as
as i think a lot of people uh believed
it would be
yeah and just you know look at what the
president said i think that really just
put the capstone on how wild this night
has been
i mean we just don't have a precedent in
u.s modern us history i would say a
president
coming out and prematurely declaring
victory and essentially announcing an
effort to try to
somehow stop the vote of legitimately
cast votes
in the u.s presidential election we'll
see if he's gonna back up his talk with
action
uh but that really threw a big
curveball and uh shocked a lot of people
tonight
all right jordan fabian bloomberg's
white house correspondent there
in dc for us i'm kirimi mori and you're
watching bloomberg quick take